what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard and this is the channel
where we talk about all things data data
science statistics and programming so
subscribe for all kinds of content just
like this if you haven't already and hit
the notification bell so youtube
notifies you whenever i upload a video
so i always talk about data science
being the intersection of statistics
programming
business or the underlying domain that
is and communication
and
communication is a part that i think
gets overlooked a lot i know i don't
talk about it on this channel probably
as much as i should
but nevertheless it is really important
and one of the most fundamental ways
that you communicate when you do really
anything with data is through data
visualization
and when you put a when you put any kind
of dashboard or graphic or anything like
that together
there are certain underlying principles
there that can help you figure out hey
is this a really good graph is it
telling a good quality story or is it
bad worse yet is it is it ugly or is it
just flat out misleading
so
i think a good starting framework here
for
evaluating the quality of your graphs or
anybody else's really is edward tufte's
six principles of graphical integrity
so
edward tufte is a statistician from yale
university and so he wrote this book
which is
great read which i highly recommend and
the link to it will be in the
description of this video
the book's the visual display of
quantitative information
and it's a very detailed and thorough
book with more ideas than just these but
essentially he put together six
principles of graphical integrity and
now
this author radica r did a linkedin
pulse
article all about this which i think is
one of the best reads on the internet
for actually summarizing these
principles
so we're going to go through these today
and also just just demonstrate some
examples of where these things are
getting violated so hopefully you won't
do the same mistakes in your own work
so before we get into this take just a
fraction of a second to smash the like
button and if you'd like to go above and
beyond to support my channel
i'll have links in the description of
this video to my patreon account as well
as to my crypto wallet addresses
all right so the first principle is that
the representation of numbers as
physically measured on the surface of
the graphic itself
should be directly proportional to the
numerical quantities measured now what
does that mean
so if we look at this infographic here
this comes from yahoo and fox sports
this is basically a bar chart
summarizing some kind of marketing
campaign and comparing uh the number of
uh of three different types of jerseys
that were sold
and so
the first problem which is sort of
unrelated here is you'll notice this
person appears on the graph here but
this is not something that really adds
anything to the graph you'll it's this
is common in infographics out there to
get your eyeballs on the graph really
quick
uh but ultimately it's distracting it
has the potential even to be somewhat
confusing
and tough day actually talks about
what's known as the data ink ratio which
is the ratio of ink on the graphic that
actually goes toward representing data
and you want that data ink ratio to be
as high as possible
now because this person doesn't add
anything to the graph uh there's no data
represented by that person there's
really no reason for them to be on here
at all again it just
it's just distracting and confusing but
the main problem with this graph is
actually the relative size of the bars
in the graph so you'll see there's 850 k
total jew jerseys that were sold and
then 520k ronaldo jerseys that were sold
but if you look at these two bars the
850k bar is barely bigger than the 520k
bar
but 520k to 850k is actually something
like a 63 increase it's a much bigger
increase than what you see represented
in the relative size of the bars
so
that's misleading but what's even worse
is if you look at the neymar jerseys
that were sold that's all the way down
there at 10k which is
about two percent of 520k
but you'll notice this bar is about
maybe one quarter of the size of this
520k bar
uh when really it should be closer to
like two percent of the size of the bar
so
again there's all kinds of things that
are wrong with this graph
and if you take a graph that under to
the untrained eye
i'm sure it looks a lot less fancy but
if you actually make the bars uh
geometrically proportional to the data
that's being represented in them you'll
see here's the 850k bar then 520k is
again this one is about 63 bigger
and then you've got this super tiny 10k
bar down here again this may look less
fancy
but it's but it's objectively a much
better graph
now moving on to principle number two
clear detailed and thorough labeling
should be used to defeat graphical
distortion and ambiguity write out
explanations of the data on the graphic
itself and
as necessary you can label important
events in the data
so this one is pretty straightforward
and self-explanatory but it could be
helpful to look at a bad example
so if we look at this graphic here
there's again all kinds of things that
are wrong with it
so part of labeling a graph includes
putting some kind of title on it
typically there's no title on here and
there's also no x and y labels so that's
that's problematic so i don't really
know what anything here is supposed to
represent
and this is something that you can run
into if you're using something like
ggplot2 and r to create a graph because
often what it'll do is it'll generate
your bars in order of the factors as
they appear in the data and that can get
problematic because what you see here is
it goes two and then one dash terrible
so the one represents a terrible but we
don't know what the two
represents does that correspond to some
kind of um of verbal kind of category
then it's three okay and four again no
category for it
five fine and dandy and then n a
so you want some kind of clear labeling
again on the axis here and then you want
these to be a lot more clean and
consistent and in order so what that
often will look like again if you're
using something like ggplot2 you'll have
to go in and actually
order the factors in the in the order
that you want uh but then also change
the labels on them but if you do that
it's it's really going to make the graph
tell a much much better story than this
does
all right now the third principle of
graphical integrity is show data
variation not design variation
and this is getting back to the
principle of the data ink ratio where as
much ink as possible on your graph
should be used to represent the data and
nothing else
and specifically when you see variation
on the graph
that should completely be just to
represent variation in the underlying
data so let's look at a bad example
where this where this is not put into
practice
so
when i looked at this graph at first it
took me way too long to figure out what
was actually going on on it
essentially what it's doing is
it's comparing opec oil prices over time
but it's doing it at first on a yearly
scale so 1973 to 1978
and then it drills down into the year
1979
to look at it by quarter and i guess the
intention with this graph was to
illustrate that it was really
skyrocketing in the year 1979 and in
fact uh so much that you could look at
it that what would normally be a year's
worth of variation showed up uh in in
quarters
but it's so hard to figure out what's
actually going on in this graph because
you have all this ink that's going on
over here and uh going on here uh above
these bars here where again it does
nothing to actually
illustrate anything uh i'm looking at
this like oh what what's actually
encoded in here like what is this and
again it's just confusing to me it made
me take away longer than i should to
figure out what was going on here and i
think a much
cleaner way of illustrating the same
information would just be hey just plot
1973 through 1978 make that in one graph
and then in like some caption below that
say that but now you see those years now
let's look at 1979 and just make that a
separate graph rather than just try to
throw all of it into one graph like this
i think it'd be a little bit longer and
there's other ways that you could do it
but that'd be a much better approach to
this fourth principle is another pretty
simple one but it's that in time series
displays of money deflated and
standardized units of monetary
measurement are nearly always better
than nominal units
so
what this is saying in short is if
you're doing any kind of monetary sort
of graph it's you want to adjust for
inflation and in the year 2022 when i'm
recording this that's obviously a pretty
important topic
so there's not an example of this in
this
uh article but i found this one in
another presentation on top of these
principles which again it's coming back
to oil prices in the 70s but you have
the nominal prices as they're measured
in uh us dollars but then you have
nominal versus real dollars so
real sort of measures in terms of uh
well relative goods and services
basically that's a real form of dollars
where it's adjusted for inflation and
you'll see in this case it's actually
not so bad of a rampant increase as
maybe it looks like
uh but another example i can think of
where this shows up all the time is
actually the stock market so you'll see
graphs sometimes in the stock market and
well it looks like it's on this
parabolic uh run-up when actually if you
would adjust for inflation over that
time it's really not quite as impressive
as it looks so
again that's just something that you
want to be looking for when you're doing
any kind of time series uh graph
and looking at money
fifth principle is the number of
information carrying dimensions depicted
should not exceed the number of
dimensions in the data so this is pretty
much an entire principle all about the
idea of do not use a 3d graphic uh when
you have only two variables or when
you're you just have a bar chart and
you're summarizing counts or something
like that it's completely unnecessary
it's another one of those things that
increases the ink uh on the graph but
doesn't necessarily uh do anything or
tell you anything else
so
again to just pull up an example of this
uh you have first class second class and
third class and this is a bar chart and
it is broken up into female and male
passengers in a snack bar chart fashion
uh but there's no reason for this to be
in 3d you see that it's a lot harder to
actually visualize the counts i have to
strain a little bit to figure out okay
there's just under 300 first class
passengers uh just over 200 second class
and so on um i will say in keeping with
one of the earlier principles and
putting accurate uh labels on the graph
um whoever wrote um this this vignette
here did a nice job of putting bad on
this graphic because it is a bad graphic
so that part is good um but again don't
use don't use 3d graphics when you don't
have to
and another
sort of principle here that's that's not
necessarily what this is saying but that
i personally think i'm not a big fan of
graphs where you have uh
two different y axes so you have two
different variables that are measured
and you see one on the left side and one
on the right side so sort of two
variables represented in that way i'm
not a fan of that either um that one is
maybe a little bit more subjective but i
think it all speaks to just a
broader overlying principle here which
is
keep the graphs as simple as possible
now the sixth principle is arguably the
most important of any of them and it's
that graphics must not quote data out of
context
so let's look at a uh example of this
so
this graph here is from fox news from
2013
and they're basically trying to tell the
story that
there are a lot more apprehensions at
the border
from 2011 going into 2013.
so they're already violating one
important rule the first one so you'll
notice this bar is more than double the
size of this bar even though 165k to
192k is nowhere near uh one being double
the other
and they're also doing this somewhat by
starting the graph at
155k or just under that
generally as much as possible you want
to start a graph y-axis and zero
but above that they're also take sort of
cherry-picking this and taking this out
of the broader context which is that
since 2008 the numbers were all higher
so there may have been an uptick from
2011 to 2013 but
years which are omitted in this graph
2008 to 2010 are higher so
again this is one of those things that
tells a very misleading incomplete sort
of story and
actually this piece here graphics not
must not quote data out of context
that's not just limited to graphs you
can do this with tables you can do this
with any kind of study or analysis of
data so stat statistics data science all
these things can be used to lie and it's
really easy to do it you can do it by
quoting things out of context telling
incomplete stories uh simpsons paradox
type of problem type of situations where
you've got things that are true in the
aggregate which aren't true in subgroups
or vice versa
cherry picking there's all kinds of
examples of this so it really is
something that you need to be careful
and mindful about
and the final thing i'll say about this
one and we'll end on this note is that
whenever you create any kind of graph
you are pretty much telling some kind of
story and it is important that that
story be accurate
so okay you got the graph to look nice
but do you understand the the underlying
data the assumptions that went into
generating that data do you understand
you know solid statistical principles
all of those things are going to go into
okay you had that graph now you've got
to interpret it for somebody probably
and really tell them what it is that
graph and the underlying data
represented there are actually saying
and so
that can be a harder job than it sounds
like at first but ultimately that's
that's why you make the big bucks in
data science as well as uh data
analytics and business analytics in
general
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it once again smash the like
button and leave me a comment down below
let me know what your experiences have
been with uh with data visualization
have you seen some really bad graphs out
there tell me all about them down below
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future
until then richard
on data